there is no minimalist rulebook well
until now the minimalists have created
16 rules for living with less a free
ebook which you can download right now
and the minimalists com /resources enjoy
I'd love to hear an expert discuss how
the stoic practice of imagining the
worst possible outcomes can help prepare
us to deal with tragedy before it
happens this reminds me my grandfather
used to always say this and I actually
do practices sometimes it's like if
you're hesitant to do something think
about the worst possible outcome and if
you can handle that outcome go ahead and
do it I don't think that works 100% for
me but but yeah I think that's what my
grandpa was saying is very similar to
teks question here well I think it kind
of goes back to something we were
talking about earlier in the podcast and
that is mortality salience right so
what's the worst possible thing that
could happen to anyone someone you love
dying yes I think about that all day
every day
I really do I start with you know the
people I love the most and then move
into you know my next circle and then my
next circle and of course my animals are
in there you know like I'm away from my
animals and I think to myself I thought
to myself this morning I have a goat I
love named Marta and Marta is like my
little sweetheart and I thought what if
something happens to her right and you
know and there's nothing you can you
can't control control is an illusion oh
yeah I mean I can control whether or not
I step to the right or step to the left
but the big things if I have a brain
aneurysm I can't control that right and
so I think about it all the time so
worst possible outcome under every
circumstance is losing someone we love
to death yeah yeah even with the
stepping to the right into the left
thing are a lot of scientists like
people like Sam Harris who would say you
can't even control that like what we
have no free will even with respect to
like can I step left what made you stuff
laughing oh all of these sort of events
collided over the last 13.7 billion
years that made you decide the stuff
left right and so I think that I think
it's a it's an important point to
realize that we don't have control but
also looking at the events helps us
deal with the tragedy before it happens
in a way if we know you you have someone
who is dying like when my mother was
dying for example like it was something
that I had to deal with she was dying of
cancer and and so yeah it was different
from had she got into a car crash say
like there was some time to sort of
prepare with it but even when it
happened you're still not completely
prepared yeah that's a big loss mom is a
big loss right and watching your mom go
through cancer
that's like prolonged trauma it is yeah
so so does like sitting there and
imagining the worst-case scenario
so when Josh found out his mother had
cancer and she wasn't necessarily
terminal when when she first I mean
that's not that wasn't so Stage four
okay so so yeah and there was some hope
there but I guess like immediately
thinking about giving up all hope in the
worst-case scenario does that help with
the actual event I think it depends on
the person yeah and their personality
characteristics right yeah you know yeah
and I hope mean different things to
different people it says hope says
something about the future right and so
does despair I don't think what Teague
is saying here should I despair but but
yeah I I knew pretty much like I did
have hope but it wasn't blind optimism
either it was my mom has stage 4 cancer
have people gotten rid of that for sure
it had metastasized and and it made her
chances a lot less but hope doesn't also
doesn't mean that I think she's going to
live forever either it means okay how
many months she have left and and by the
way we all have a certain number of
months left regardless if were one month
old or you know or a hundred years old
we have a finite time here good but it
gets back to what you were talking about
earlier all we have is now and it did
help me appreciate that now with her
then and actually we we did we did a lot
of work repairing our relationship over
the course of that next year as as she I
spent a lot of time with her although I
certainly wish I would have spent I
would have had more time
and nothing no no there's not but we had
a lot of nails and a lot of important
now's yeah that were very helpful so
maybe having that thought process of my
mom's probably gonna pass away maybe
what that does instead of helping you
deal with like that actual event it kind
of helps you maybe take some actions
that you know you would that you grant
yes exactly yeah so you can take some
actions like you and your mom helped you
know you guys prepared a relationship a
little bit so certainly that feels
better I would think than her passing
and then not trying to repair that
relationship she was so I got the phone
call from her it was two days before
Christmas 2008 when she found out and if
I would have gotten the phone call that
day it and it would have been hey your
mom has got into a car accident she's no
longer here hmm that would have been
even more difficult right it would have
even been more traumatic although
they're sometimes a prolong sort of
death like that can can be more
traumatic depending on the individual
right it's it's they're both traumatic
they're just traumatic in different ways
yes